this one's going to work like a charm
wordsmiths because the word we're
featuring in this video is
effective effective it's an adjective
meaning successful good at something the
etymology the the derivation of this
word helps explain it I think three
Latin Parts first one f is a modified
form of X meaning out the second one
fact or fact comes from a Latin verb
that means to make
right and and just those two on their
own give us effect right an effect is an
outcome a thing that you made happen
what comes out of a process I hit a
watermelon with a baseball bat that's a
sound effect right oh okay and finally
Ive if an adjective forming suffix it
has a meaning of tending to something
that is effective tends to or has the
quality of making things happen of of
making outcomes easily powerfully all
right let's look for similar related
words think of some words that have that
eff F that F beginning or fact or fact
in them or end in Ive end in
if I'll put on some music 10 seconds
here we
[Music]
go so here are three that I came up with
effusive this is an adjective meaning
pouring out like you might shower
someone with effusive praise it has that
F prefix right the modified form of X
meaning out then confection this word
means candy or sweets though it
literally means a thing that is made
together right confection a mixed thing
a combination of sweets and a third
related word is Factor
a place where things are made a shoe
factory a chocolate factory a car
factory that ory ending oy is a noun
forming suffix that means a place for
like like laboratory or Observatory
let's use the word effective in a
sentence or two Marissa realized how
effective her marketing campaign had
been when she saw the line stretching
around the block it worked extremely
well the marketing campaign did and now
everyone wants to buy her donuts donuts
the universal food let me show you
another one the article that Devin wrote
about iy corpse scummy labor practices
was so effective that it put them out of
business nobody wanted to work with them
anymore these weird business blobs that
leave a trail of
Goo I wonder what they made at icky Corp
actually no no I do not want to
know but here's what I do want to know I
want you to know that you can learn
anything David out